i believe
that self-discipline is
the definition of self-love
that when you say that you love yourself
that means that
you have behavior towards yourself
that is loving it's like you say to
yourself hey man look
i know you want to eat that pizza and
it'll be really good
you know but i can't let you eat that
man cause if
you eat that pizza you're gonna feel
like you know and i
i just i love you too much to let you
eat that
and i think the word discipline has kind
of gotten
a bad name we think about it in terms of
punishment i'm not talking about
discipline in that way i'm talking about
discipline
in the sense that you you forego
immediate pleasure
for the exchange of long-term
self-respect self-love
is when you say to yourself ah man
look i know you and that girl got a real
connection
um i know y'all vibe but
that's your girl's cousin so
i love you too much to let you do that
self-love is a look
i know you got a test on monday you know
and i know you really want to go out
with your friends and saturday night you
want to go out but
if you fail that test you're not going
to feel good about yourself
you know i just i love you too much to
let you go out tonight
self-discipline is self-love
if you want to be happy you have to love
yourself
which means you have to discipline your
behavior
the road to sustained
happiness is through disciplining
your behavior i just saw this roomy
quote
that i love set your life on fire
and seek those who fan your flames the
philly translation of that
is don't be hanging with no jank ass
jokers
that don't help you shine the
prerequisite for spending time
with any person is that they nourish
and inspire you they feed your flame
there's been very few times in my life
that i looked left or looked right and
didn't find
a person who believed and supported me
from jazzy jeff to alfonso ribeiro
to charlie mack to jada like there's
always been a person beside me fanning
my flames
look at your last five text messages
are those people feeding your flames
or dousing your fire put your phone down
for just a second and look
around look to the people around you are
those people
throwing logs on your fire or are they
pissing on it
the people that you spend time with are
gonna make or break your dreams
everybody don't deserve to be around you
you got to defend your light
with your life if you don't have a goal
yeah you know
if you don't have a purpose for your
relationship and pretty much anything
it's like
if you don't have a purpose if you don't
have a place that you're you're
going something that you want to
accomplish something you want to do
you can really get lost in the murk of
the the journey but as an
answer for why two spirits would join
together and decide to travel
this perilous journey of life together
fine or you can cook or you keep the
house protected that's really not enough
there's so much
more that you have to be dedicated to i
was
introduced by my mother and grandmother
to
resurrection baptist church in west
philly
and it was really important
to serve
higher goals right i just feel like
all of the blessings that that i have
you know with my wife and my my family
and extended family
there's no way that
god intended that just for acting i'm
energized every day by
just what the possibilities are in
bringing
bringing the kids up now is like oh my
goodness it's a whole new
uh burst of energy and burst of of
possibilities
of what we can do in this world
as a family uh my grandmother my
grandmother
she she used to smile all the time gigi
was just
always happy yeah and uh we were
actually going into
uh resurrection uh one day and i was
gigi
how come you'd be smiling all the time
and she said cause i know what i'm here
to do baby
and i said well what's that she said
i'll just i'm gonna make everything i
touch better
i love this one fail early fail often
fail forward um you know it's always a
little bit frustrating to me when people
have a negative relationship with
failure
failure is a massive part of being able
to be
successful you have to get comfortable
with failure yeah you have to actually
seek failure failure is where all of the
lessons are
you know when you go to the gym and you
work out you're actually
seeking failure you want to take your
muscles to the point
where you get to failure because that's
where the the adaptation is that's where
growth is successful people fail
a lot they fail a whole lot more than
they succeed but they extract the
lessons
from the failure and they use that the
the energy and they use the wisdom
to come around to the next phase of
success you gotta take a shot you have
to live
at the edge of your capabilities you got
to live
where you're almost certain you're going
to fail
that's the reason for practice practice
is controlled
failure you're getting to your limit
getting to your limit getting to your
limit
you can't lift that you can't do that
you until
you get to the point that all of a
sudden your body makes the adjustment
and then you can do it failure uh
actually helps you
to recognize the areas where you need to
evolve
so fail early fail often
fail forward for me it's really basic
if you set your priorities you you start
at the top
and every day you start at your first
priority and you work your way down
and when it's time to go to sleep you go
to sleep and you don't worry about
whatever you missed
and you wake up the next day and start
at the top of your priorities
again then you just keep going till you
don't have energy and that that
to me that works uh it works very well
and i just have to make sure that i keep
my priorities
in order because you don't want to uh
slip and be dealing with number eight
on your priority list and you haven't
dealt with number three yet
in my mind i just refuse to allow myself
to concentrate on drawbacks
you have to learn how to fight and
defend yourself
from predators without letting your
heart go dark
and that's a an extremely difficult
difficult balance but i would i wouldn't
trade this life
for anything i love
being me the daily confrontation
um with with fear has become a real
practice for me since about three
three years ago um i went uh
i went skydiving in dubai right
and skydiving skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear right so
so i got to i got to stand up i got to
stand up all right
so so all your friends what happens you
go out
how are you oh sorry i dropped my thing
so what happens is
you go out the night before and you you
know you take a drink with your friends
and somebody says yeah we should go
skydiving tomorrow
and you go yeah we'll go skydiving yeah
yeah
yeah and everybody goes yeah right and
you go home but you by yourself you're
like
right you're like well yeah i mean they
was drunk too
right so so maybe maybe they not maybe
maybe i mean
we don't have to go we don't have to do
it so then that night you're laying in
your bed and you just keep
and you're terrified you keep imagining
over and over again
jumping out of an airplane and you can't
figure out why you would do that
right and you're laying there and you
have the worst night's sleep of your
life but you still have the hope that
your friends were drunk
right so you wake up the next day and
you go you know down and you say where
you were going to meet and
everybody's there you're like oh um
[Music]
all right all right cool cool cool cool
cool cool right
so you get in the van and you don't know
that your friends had the same night
that you had because they're pretending
like
they didn't they're like yeah man my
uncle's a navy seal
and you know this is gonna be great i've
been looking forward to this and you're
like oh my god
oh my god and your stomach is terrible
you can't eat and everything but you
don't want to be the only punk who
doesn't jump out of this airplane
so you get there and then you have the
safety brief
and you're standing there and the guys
will tell you well if the chute doesn't
open what's going to happen is you're
doing
well why the hell what could happen that
the shoot
the shoot wouldn't open right so you do
a thing and what you do is your first
jump you're attached to a guy
who is going you know he's going to walk
you out so you go
and you get there and there's an
airplane and nobody's stopping
everybody's still going so you get onto
the airplane
and you're sitting there and and you
know it's extra because you're sitting
on some dude's lap some stranger
he's sitting on his lap and it's like
you know you're trying to make small
talk yeah man
you you be jumping with people all the
time
right you know so and then you just want
to make sure you got you have kids right
you got people you need to see
right you just want to make sure he's
serious right so you get in there
so everything's normal so you fly and
you go up you go up you go up you go up
to 14
000 feet and you notice there's a light
it's red
and it's yellow and green right so right
now the light's red
so then you start thinking at some point
the light's gonna go green because you
don't know what's gonna happen
right and you wait and it goes yellow
and the light goes green
and somebody opens the door and in that
moment you realize you've never been in
a freaking airplane with the door open
right terror no sorry i'm spitting
sorry no terror terror terror
terror right so you go
and then you know if you're if you were
smart you sat in the back so you don't
go first
right and then people start going out of
the airplane
and you go and the guy walks you up
to the end of the thing and you're
standing and your toes
are on the edge and you're looking out
down to death
and they say on three and they say
one two and he pushes you on two because
people
grab on three right
right and you go
and you fall out of the airplane and in
one
second you realize that it's the most
blissful experience of your
life you're flying right it doesn't feel
like
falling right it's like the you actually
are kind of held a little bit
by the wind and then you start and you
you start falling you've fallen and you
there's zero fear you realize that the
point of
maximum danger is the point of minimum
fear it's bliss it's
bliss and you're flying
right and you're doing it and then 20
seconds
25 seconds 40 seconds and you have
enough time to just kind of be like oh
that's that building that's not like
that one
oh you can see the ocean right you start
doing all of that and
the the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before
why did you what do you need that fear
for just don't go
why are you scared in your bed 16 hours
before
you jump why are you scared in the car
why could you not enjoy breakfast what
what
what what did you need that the fear is
fear of what you're nowhere even near
the airplane
everything up to the stepping
out there's actually no reason to be
scared it only just
ruins your day you don't have to jump
and then in that moment all of a sudden
where you should be terrified
is the most blissful experience of your
life
and god placed the best things
in life on the other side of terror
on the other side of your maximum fear
are all of the best things in life
if you want some amazing affirmations
with kobe bryant check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there the important thing is to
accept them all to embrace them all
and then you can choose to do with them
which you want
versus being controlled by emotion